cominciano i controlli è tutto chiuso e
bloccato spina proprio alimenti e dei
comandi liberi non credi apcom stream
per il decollo treno parcheggio stolto
mauri confine giro bustone 059 205 9
bianchi e colorati i tempi
un affronto che cosa
buongiorno a tutti
buongiorno e lo so siete tutti delusi
vero perché dopo un video così uno si
aspetta uno alto biondo con i capelli
lunghi e occhi azzurri uomini vi è
andata bene donne di andata male beh io
nonostante quello che potete pensare a
una cosa molto bella mi emoziono sempre
nella vita mi emoziono sempre
e sono una persona estremamente
fortunata la prima cosa che vi voglio
dire e sono qui perché poi ho studiato
non mi sono preparato il terreno l'idea
e mi sono detto cose gli racconto beh
innanzitutto non sono qui per insegnare
per voglio solo raccontarvi qual è la
mia idea
il mio punto di vista su come possiamo
secondo me oggi cambiare il modo di
ragionare guardare le cose per
migliorare e cambiare in meglio il
momento che stiamo vivendo e traggo
tutto questo dagli insegnamenti che io
ho colto nel mio percorso che è il
percorso della persona estremamente
fortunata
io ho iniziato mi ricordo quand'ero
ragazzino mio papà era un mito però una
persona molto diciamo dalle regole
chiare e severe tutti io per entrare a
parlare con lui era come se dovessi
andare a parlare con l'amministratore
delegato quindi devo bussare vince va
avanti entravo papà voglio fare il
concorso in accademia aeronautica e e
lui mi disse ok mi piace molto sono
molto fiero di te però sappi che se
l'impegno che hai messo finora l'impegno
che messo finora le cose che hai fatto
non sarà sufficiente e io da lì ho
iniziato percorso in cui ho lavorato su
me stesso perché non era una persona che
si impegnava tantissimo nelle cose che
sono riuscito sono state in accademia
fatto il pilota militare sono entrato
sono stato selezionato per le frecce ne
sono diventato il comandante finito con
le frecce nel 2010
ho iniziato a lavorare per un noto brand
automobilistico e faccio tante altre
cose e sono un piccolo giovane
imprenditore e ma soprattutto e tutto
questo perché perché condivido mi sa con
tutti voi penso di essere nel posto
giusto e ho sentito queste parole da
dagli speaker che mi hanno preceduto
passione io non sono una persona che si
appassiona non sono un maniaco di una
cosa specifica
tutti mi dicono amatulli aerei e tutto
no sapete con la mia passione più grande
l'arte non c'entra niente però alla mia
passione più grande e io ho una
curiosità incredibile e su qualsiasi
cosa
non penso che ci sia una cosa più bella
di un'altra penso che viviamo in un
mondo straordinario con luoghi
bellissimi in cielo sulle montagne sotto
la terra è che l'uomo in grado di fare
cose straordinarie e che certe volte il
limite a quello che possiamo fare siamo
solo noi stessi e partendo dalla mia
esperienza voglio raccontarvi come per
esempio in nate nel team in cui ho
vissuto io
dove se sbagli se sbagli non perdi un
business o una gara ma mette a
repentaglio la cosa più importante che
abbiamo contano valori che spesso
diciamo noi dimentichiamo e che invece
poi se guardati anche in senso più ampio
ci possono aiutare in ogni momento della
nostra vita perché è con tassi la
professionalità con tassi quanto siamo
bravi a fare le cose conta quanto
abbiamo studiato ma conta tantissimo
come ci comportiamo i quali sono le
nostre qualità umane che secondo me
tutti abbiamo ma spesso per il tipo di
società in cui viviamo vengono
nascoste la cosa che conta di più è la
stima e la fiducia tra le persone però
voglio dirvi che facciamo un po di
confusione secondo me sotto questi punti
di vista
stima e fiducia cosa vuol dire non vuol
mica dire fare il tifo per la stessa
squadra di calcio non vuol mica dire
amare lo stesso tipo di pizza e uscire
tutti insieme quella sera lì perché
abbiamo lo stesso hobby o passione stima
e fiducia derivano da tutt'altro stima e
fiducia derivano da un certo tipo di
comportamento una persona di cui tu hai
fiducia e la fiducia si guadagna la
persona che ha delle comportamenti non
perfetti perché io sono tutt'altro che
perfetto però nei comportamenti e basici
estremamente semplici come la
trasparenza la condivisione con te di
delle cose
l'umiltà che tra l'altro ci aiuta a non
causare uno dei problemi più grossi in
quei team che lover confidence
l'autocompiacimento che sono problemi
che viviamo come società e ci limitano
nel cambiamento perché siamo convinti
che quello che facciamo tutto perfetto e
abbiamo sempre fatto così e va bene
invece non va bene quindi l'umiltà è un
fattore importante e soprattutto
attenzione perché prima di tutto la
parola stime la parola fiducia è una
parola importante perché non basta dire
a una persona di quella collegano mi
fido mi sbaglia le lettere ci sono cose
più importanti magari poi in autostrada
di notte su una corsia sull'autostrada
due corsie diluvia superiamo un tiro più
paura di fare quello che affidare una
lettera a una mia collega tant'è vero
che io per mia regola
io do fiducia la mia prima azione tu sei
mio amico lavori con me io ti dò fiducia
dopo vediamo
secondo non è detto che una persona che
i cui e fiducia la pensi sempre come te
anzi this ratti voi vi fidate di un
amico che vi dice sempre che avete
ragione voi io se poi avete un amico che
vi dice che avete sempre ragione mi
farei una domanda l'amico vero ti dice
anche anche facendo ti arrabbiare che
secondo lui quel giorno lì tu hai torto
ea ragione quell'altro perché pensa che
quello sì altro bene in questi team
queste cose sono fondamentali le persone
devono potersi parlare e volendo parlare
poi di come funzionano
in realtà io quando ero il comandante
delle frecce volevo persone che mi
dicessero capo sei alto bello biondo hai
sempre ragione oggi no oggi stai
sbagliando
per questo motivo da noi si diceva
bisogna accendere il cervello pensare a
quello che si deve dire ma se si hanno i
contenuti si può dire anzi si deve dire
è un dovere perché magari da una mia
decisione poteva scaturire un errore che
poteva casa ora una tragedia
io volevo essere volevo avere un
percorso un processo che evitasse
determinati tipi di problemi e non viene
meno la tua professionalità o la tua
leadership
anzi perché poi sei sempre tu che
comunque decidi però se tu hai delle
teste che lavorano e pensano con te le
devi sfruttare è una parola brutta ma
bella in questo momento perché sono
teste pensanti che devono darti quelli
che io chiamo i contributi di pensiero
che forniscono a chi gestisce a chi
comanda e a chi si prende la
responsabilità perché il capo decide per
responsabilità di prendere decisione
migliore io sono un amante della
diversità
una delle mie regole se è stata meno
male che siamo tutti diversi perché
persone diverse riescono a vedere lo
stesso problema da punti di vista
diversi
quindi riescono analizzare tutti quegli
elementi che dobbiamo prendere in
considerazione per poi prendere la
strada migliore la decisione migliore
non quella perfetta
purtroppo li sarà difficile ma
sicuramente la migliore e attenzione
ricordatevi che quando io sento a io
sono fortunato il mio capo mi fa parlare
in realtà è lui che è un grande perché
ha capito che può cogliere delle
opportunità e lui fortunato tu hai il
dovere di parlare e di dire che guardate
che questo tipo di rapporto e di
confronto estremamente importante per
poi gestire anche il proprio futuro non
solo all'interno dell'ambiente
lavorativo io sono una persona curiosa
mi piace cambiare cambio spesso il
cambiamento me lo cerco io come
opportunità ma soprattutto sono sempre
attento a capire che cosa può succedere
perché troppe volte nella nostra storia
qualcuno ha detto a questo non potrà mai
accadere
invece poi è fallito perché quella cosa
lì è accaduta perché è stato già detto
bellissima questa cosa questa continuità
viviamo spesso di stereotipi vi diamo
sempre di un costruito che è dettato dal
nostro momento da quello che abbiamo
imparato da quello che abbiamo studiato
da quello che viviamo da quello che ci
diciamo che i nostri amici al bar e
questo ci limita in maniera enorme nel
prendere la strada giusta
non siamo sempre purtroppo
sufficientemente aperti a quello che
viene lì e ti dice una cosa che esce dal
tuo normale conosciuto in quel momento
lì non siamo capaci e questo è un limite
credetemi
poi alcuni concetti più mani una persona
di cui e fiducia è una persona che ti
rispetta indipendentemente dal fatto che
potuto avere un'opinione diversa ti
rispetta ti tratta bene ti saluta le
persone in quanto tali sono tutte uguali
e sono i ruoli che cambiano le
responsabilità
c'è chi decide si che ci che supporta c
che fa un certo ruolo però le persone
sono uguali quindi per esempio tutti si
devono salutare tutti meritano il
buongiorno tutti meritano i come stai e
in più ricordiamoci anche che la vita
una ruota e la giornata storta la
possiamo avere tutti e non può
condizionare questo il rapporto tra le
persone
queste cose in quella esperienza sono
fondamentali io poi ho imparato a vedere
quanto si riflettono anche nel modo in
cui magari ci mettiamo a trattare
argomenti che vanno al di là
dell'ambiente lavorativo
in effetti però come potete notare le
persone che fanno parte dei determinante
squadre sono persone normali non sono
supereroi sono persone io io ho imparato
a dire che sono semplicemente persone
equilibrate persone che sbagliano
cercano di rimediare persone che hanno
la capacità di ascoltare tutti perché da
chiunque
c'è qualcosa da imparare se qualcuno di
voi dovesse chiedermi massimo qual è il
tuo vero pregio il pregio più importante
ma io ho difficoltà dirvi quale preso
veramente grosso 1 me ne viene in mente
mi viene sempre in mente lo ha eletto a
mio pregio principale è quello che non
ho mai pensato di trovarmi di fronte una
persona che è inferiore a me a priori
chiunque seduto davanti a me ha qualcosa
da raccontarmi che io posso prendere
perché sa fare una cosa che io non so
fare perché non è che se si come sono
stato comandante le frecce che ho fatto
mille altre cose so fare tutto
io se vi si rompe il lavandino a casa
devo chiamarli traffico
ho bisogno di lui così come abbiamo
bisogno tutti di tutti per fare
determinate cose e ogni cosa che vediamo
può essere bella e quindi questo e alla
fine è un gesto di umiltà che aiuta
anche quando arriva la persona che ti
dice una cosa che va un po fuori e il
rispetto si tramuta anche nel modo in
cui ci diciamo le cose perché non è
esprimere una opinione diversa il
problema è il modo in cui lo diciamo che
fa la differenza
quello è fondamentale è un'altra cosa
che dobbiamo imparare a fare è una
risposta che io do sempre quando mi
chiedono sentiva come facevi a gestire
lo stress come facevi a gestire momenti
in cui avevi quel carico sia fisico che
psicologico chiaro preparazione atletica
addestramento fatta più in patapam
chiaro chiarissimo però nella vita
quando lo dico nelle aziende mi guardano
subito storto poi spiego bisogna essere
capaci a ridare la priorità giusta alle
cose io avevo un collega chi uno dei
mari miei vari ambienti lavorativi che
stava vicino a me quando parlava le
urlava si arrabbiava io avevo paura di
prendesse un colpo quindi un giorno sono
entrato nel suo ufficio per troppo alti
detto socio che che ho scusate siamo
tutti i soci e che è successo a massimo
e fanno arrabbiare qua non puoi capire
io e mentre lui parlava gli dicevo sono
entrato tipo calciatore a gamba tesa da
dietro
l'ho interrotto gli ho parlato sopra gli
ho detto come statua figlia bene come
statua moglie bene basta cioè non sei
autorizzato a farti venire una viscera
per cose che non siano queste che questo
credetemi in quel lavoro gli è
fondamentale perché capisci cosa conta
però aiuta sempre perché perché nel
momento in cui per esempio sul lavoro ci
viene chiesto un task un obiettivo
difficile essere freschi veloci sereni
aiuta per assurdo la performance per
forma molto 1 me è molto meglio uno che
fa questo perchè è lucido piuttosto che
uno che va in panico perché non si
ricorda che e noi spesso ci pensate vi
diamo male un 3 mesi perchè ci hanno
rigato la macchina oppure un anno perché
è successa un'altra cavolata dobbiamo
imparare a fare questo
e alla fine io voglio invitarvi e questa
è la mia idea a ragionare sul fatto che
nel mondo stanno succedendo un tante
cose io ho avuto la fortuna anche di
studiare all'estero e di vivere in mondi
dove ero l'unico italiano in contesti
con tantissime diversità etniche
religiose tutto dobbiamo imparare a
farci la nostra idea
dobbiamo essere ancora più curiose di
quello che siamo e dobbiamo stare
attenti perché il mondo sta cambiando
talmente tanto ed è difficile cioè volte
accettare che per esempio arrivi uno e
ci dica botta qualche anno le macchine
guideranno da sole saranno tutte
elettriche e insieme a huber
la macchina non sarà più un mezzo di
utilizzo ma solo di trasporto per cui tu
col cellulare chiami la macchina lei
arriva sotto da sola 50 metri prima
scaricato qualcun altro questo vuol dire
anche che serviranno meno autostrade
perché le macchine saranno meno meno
parcheggi quanto pensate si allontana
questa cosa qui io vi posso assicurare
che non è così lontana come la
percepiamo noi qui quindi vi prego
partendo da queste regolette che ho
imparato è che gestisco ricordatevi che
non riusciremo mai a gestire un futuro
se non ci rispettiamo quindi ma ci
diciamo le cose come stanno
quindi ci dobbiamo dire quello che
pensiamo rispettando l'opinione altrui
se non abbiamo la mente aperta quindi se
non andiamo oltre quello che noi
pensiamo non facciamo lo sforzo di
guardare oltre quell'ostacolo se non
abbiamo la possibilità di farci
challenge
anche al capo challenge vuol dire di
dire al capo è sbagliato secondo me
scusa che ha poi provato a prendere in
considerazione questo aspetto oggi stai
sbagliando non ci potrà mai essere un
contributo reale alla squadra alla
nostra società
all all'azienda se non ci abituiamo a
generare intorno a noi un ambiente che
ci permetta di dire e scusate di pensare
di poter pensare dire l'impensabile
c'è gente che è morta sul rogo perché ha
detto che la terra era rotonda in
sintesi però ci aveva ragione lui
noi oggi stiamo facendo così su tante
altre cose c'è gente che ha detto l'auto
non potrà mai sostituire il cavallo c'è
gente che ha detto chi vorrà mai una
macchinetta digitale c'è gente che ha
detto computer a casa non l'avrà mai
nessuno
sono tutti morti l'ultima cosa se
vogliamo veramente innovare
dobbiamo scrollarci di dosso la paura di
sbagliare e l'ambiente che dobbiamo
creare intorno a noi deve essere in un
ambiente in cui c'è il permesso di
sbagliare perché se no non ci sarà la
possibilità di fare qualcosa che nessuno
ha mai fatto fino a quel momento lì
grazie
grazie mille